let's talk about the astrocytic
glutamate glutamine cycle astrocyte take
part in formation of tripartite synapse
if we zoom into a tripartite synapse we
can see the presynaptic terminal
postsynaptic terminal and astrocyte in
the presynaptic terminal when action
potential reaches the Terminus there
would be release in glutamate and
glutamate binds to postsynaptic
glutamate receptor glutamate is formed
from the presynaptic glutamine with the
help of enzyme glutaminease astrocytes
actually provide glutamine but how does
astrocyte makes the glutamine astrocyte
uptake excess glutamate with the help of
excitatory amino acid transporter and
that glucamide gets converted to
glutamine with the help of glutamine
synthetase and this is how astrocyte
clears up excess of glutamate from the
synapse and prevents the risk of
excitotoxicity too much too much of
glutamate is bad for the brain and it
might lead to epilepsy that's why
astrocity is important